[Musique]
qui aime l'argent ici
pour ces jeunes lecteurs l'agent jean
est un super rigolo
est ce que l'agent jean il un pistolet à
eau comme arles ça il faut le faire même
si est bizarre c'est quand même plus les
bras j'adore l'argent constitue c'est ça
qui se sent que l'agent jean est un
croisement entre james bond et bob
l'épongé il a vu le jour en 2011 sous
forme de bande dessinée et en sept ans
les aventures rocambolesques de ce c'est
rigolo se sont vendues à huit cent mille
exemplaires selon son éditeur
c'est leur rêve d'un éditeur d'avoir un
agent puis un alex a fait autant de gens
qui se reconnaissent dans mes mais déjà
vous n'êtes encore un mystère pour moi
qu'est ce qu'ils aiment à ce point là je
peux même pas répondre l'agent jean aura
une nouvelle mission celle de faire le
saut à la télévision ayat y est parti
dès le mois d'avril tfo et radio-canada
diffuseront dix capsules de faire
travailler une seconde les péripéties de
l'agencé des courtes saynètes c'est des
petites scènes où et c'est un calme en
ligne un punch génial voici les toutes
premières images de ces capsules prêter
attention
la voix de l'agent jean sera incarné par
le comédien pierre luc phone deuxième
place c'est déjà pas si mal
j'ai jamais entendu mes personnages dans
ma tête donc je savais pas que mentionné
l'agent j'avais une idée est ce que je
voulais pas mais quand j'ai su pierre
legrand que j'ai fait mais oui
l'entreprise
frima studio à québec a planché sur ces
capsules pendant près de six mois et le
défi était de taille
ce qui est passionnant c'est que depuis
le début du processus on a travaillé
beaucoup avec l'auteur avec alex parce
qu'on voulait être sûr de bien incarner
son univers avec cbd tous ces
personnages en animation donc la
facilité pour nous pour une fois c'est
qu'on partait personnage qui vise qui
ont déjà fait beaucoup d'albums qui sont
vraiment vraiment beau
de retour à l'école primaire budget du
vernet à montréal ici ses lecteurs ont
bien hâte de voir leur agent par le
passage au petit écran les lire
s'écouler maintenant leurs regards des
sûretés lis encore plus cool ça peut
donner
l'humour juste assez d'humour pour pour
rigoler la planète entière je pense ici
louis fait dépouiller mais radio-canada
montréal
[Musique]